saddaransky just checked into the game  former washington make someone else make  someone else beat you get it out of his  hands  zion on the run on the nice dribble  going strong to the rack  hey joe what a finesse move you want to  see a dead body  seven point lead for chicago  man i tell you what i am running out of  adjectives to describe  to describe what zion does i really am  well that time you know he kind of  cruised his way into the paint exploded  let's look at our energy power play you  see the gamble by temple  and he set his boy up for failure don't  worry about it brother we all been there  gafford  we all been there wow  elevation power explosion with defend it  don't worry about it brother we all been  there gafford  we all been there